- Thank you all for coming.
Welcome to this new
series that we've launched
with the engineering workforce development
of the Center for Quantum Network
and the Yale Quantum Institute.
We are delighted to be here.
My name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute.
And I will be moderating this panel
with my colleague, Russell Balliet
So this series, we are
kick-starting the series
with one event today
about prepare for college
because we've realized that
building quantum technology
is something that requires a lot of people
with different backgrounds.
We need physicists, we
need electrical engineer,
we need computer scientists,
software engineer, chemist.
There's a lot of traits that we need
and it can be very overwhelming
to consider a career
in quantum science and information.
And so by attending this session today,
you will hear from current students,
from staff and faculty in the field,
what it's like to work in quantum.
And hopefully you can get advice
on navigating the various
pathway that you can take.
So this event will be recorded.
So a little bit of technical
details on the zoom.
You can only see and hear the panelists.
You have a feature at
the bottom of your screen
that has the Q and A panel.
So if you click on it,
you should be able to type your questions.
And then you can also put a thumbs up
on the question you want answer the most.
And so the most requested
question will go to the top
and then Russell and
I will go through them
and ask to the panelists.
There's also closed
captioning if you want,
and this will be recorded
and you can watch it later on demand.
Before we start,
I would like to introduce
my colleague Russell Balliet
and he will be the
second moderator with me.
And he's gonna say a few words.
- Thanks, Florian.
So yeah, I'm Russell Balliet.
I'm with the center for quantum
networks and specifically
with the engineering
workforce development team.
I'm the assistant director.
So just real quick a little bit
about the center for quantum networks.
It's a national science
foundation funded center
that just got started late last year.
And we are a part of 10
different institutions
or, sorry there are 10
institutions in our center
including Yale.
I'm specifically with the
University of Arizona,
which is the lead institution.
And so the center for
quantum networks got started
because one of our big goals
is to help lay the foundation
for a socially responsible
quantum internet,
which some of you have
probably heard about
hoping that this is gonna spur
new technology industries,
competitive barter plays for
quantum service providers
and application developers
for the benefit of all.
Like I said, I'm specifically
with the engineering
workforce development team.
So a lot of what our
goals are include trying
to develop the future
workforce to be a part
of the quantum internet
and help develop it
and also help develop the quantum network.
So a lot of what we do
is outreach in trying
to educate people and try
to get people interested
in the quantum internet and technologies
and all of this kind of stuff
that some of you are
gonna hear about today.
So real quick, if there
are any teachers out there,
we are looking for some classrooms
to actually run some virtual field trips
where students will get to kind
of have an interactive peek
into some of the coolest
stuff that happens
in these labs that are
doing things related
to the quantum internet
and quantum networks.
And so I don't think
Florian mentioned this,
but why/how he got interested in quantum,
but to be honest actually I
have no background in quantum.
I have a PhD in geology, so
a lot of this is new to me
and I'm gonna be learning a lot.
But for me, I think kind
of one of the cool things
about quantum is just
how interesting it is
and just kind of the weird crazy stuff
that goes on with quantum.
So thanks Florian.
- Thank you, Russell.
So before we introduce the panelists,
since we cannot see you, we
thought that would be fun
to have a little poll
happening in the chat.
So you will see a poll
and then you can tell us
what is your interest?
Are you interested in STEM
and the current theme?
And so we can learn a little
bit more and make sure
that we target or answer to your needs.
So the poll should pop up
in your screen right now
and then I will start with the panelists.
So maybe let's start with...
So you can start turning on your web cam.
Thank you all for being here.
And then we can start with maybe Shantanu,
if you want to introduce yourself
and tell us all about what you do.
- Yeah. First of all, thanks
so much for having me here.
You know, I would really enjoy going
to such an event if I were starting off
and if I were interested,
so I'm happy to be here.
My name is Shantanu Jha.
I recently graduated from
Yale this past December.
While I was there I
studied physics and math
and I started off in
quantum information science
by doing research with professor Girvin,
one of the other panelists here today.
Later, I did research in
professor Devoret's group
in quantum engineering
(technical hitch drowns speaker)
superconducting systems, quantum platforms
on to which we realized
cubits and other cool things.
I also founded the Yale
undergrad quantum computing org.
And we can talk a bit about that later,
but through that I was able
to meet a lot of cool people
and make a lot of cool projects.
Yeah. So really happy to be here.
Hello.
- Thank you.
Ayelet, do you want to go next?
- Yeah, I would love to.
Thank you so much for having me.
My name's Ayelet Kalfus.
I'm a rising sophomore at
Yale majoring in physics
and I'm the director
of partnerships at UQC,
the organization that Shantanu
started this past year.
So it was actually a dark
November night during quarantine
when I received the email from YQI
about the upcoming lecture that night,
"Why you should care
about quantum computers".
And I know plans for that night.
So I decided to be a fun
activity for my family.
I set up the TV in our living
room and we started watching.
I hadn't really realized
that quantum computers
were something that existed
outside of Marvel movies.
And as I stopped there watching,
I just realized that this was an amazing,
exciting, interdisciplinary field
that combined a lot of my interests.
And I started to see a future
for myself within that field.
And then a few days later,
I got an email about the formation of UQC,
this undergraduate quantum computing club.
So I joined and since then
I've only grown more and more enthusiastic
about quantum computing
and my place in it.
At Yale I'm also the outreach
chair for women in physics.
I'm involved with the
student film festival.
I'm currently co-directing
a mini documentary
and I'm actually gonna be doing research
with professor Girvin this summer.
And I'm really looking forward to that.
Thank you so much.
- Well, this is the
perfect transition then
for Steve to go next.
- Hi, I'm Steve Girvin.
I'm professor of physics,
I'm professor of applied physics at Yale.
I also have temporarily
a half-time position
at Brookhaven national
laboratory where I'm the director
of the co-design center
for quantum advantage,
one of the five national
quantum information science
research centers recently
funded by the department
of energy.
I'm the faculty advisor
to the club that Shantanu
and Ayelet are helping run.
And I'm a theoretician.
I work with pencil and paper and computers
rather than hardware, but I think closely
about quantum hardware
and I'm part of the team that invented
the basic architecture for
using superconducting cubits
to try to build quantum
computers that's been adopted
by Google and IBM and Rigetti
and other companies around the world
and lots of academic places.
And maybe one fun fact about myself.
I grew up in a small village
in northern New York state,
number five kid in my high school class.
- Thanks a lot.
And then last our panelist, Kelly
to introduce yourself, please.
- Sure. Good morning, everyone.
My name is Kelly Ratliff
and I am on the recruitment
and admissions team
for the college of engineering here
at the university of Arizona,
which as you heard is one
of the partner institutions
for the center for quantum networks.
So I'm really excited to be here today.
I am not a scientist or a physicist,
but I help support those
students who will be
our future scientists and physicists.
So I work with incoming
first year students
and incoming transfer students
and help them determine their path forward
into a STEM, engineering or
maybe even a quantum career.
So I'm really pleased to be a
part of this excellent group.
And I look forward to
chatting with you all today.
Thanks for having me.
- Thank you.
And I can pull up on that saying
that there's also a lot of career.
Like when we think
about career in quantum,
we think about scientists.
We think about a lot
of people like working
on quantum science, but
there's also a lot of people
in the background.
One of the last event that
we will have in this series
would be with alternative careers
for people who are
supporting all the stuff
and all these efforts.
So we'll have that probably in December.
Okay. Let's kick start things...
Let's start these things
with our first question.
So I think this question will
be more for our two panelists,
Ayelet and Shantanu.
Can you tell us a little bit more
like what's your experience
in college and like,
how did you find out what you wanted to do
and how did you decided to study quantum?
- Yeah, sure.
I'm happy to start off.
So one of the best pieces
of advice I received
from any professor my first year
was one of my professors was talking
about who cow kids who found success
in their high school career
are often really too scared
to pivot to something else
and try something new.
I actually entered Yale
as a neuroscience major.
I felt very secure in that.
And then during my first year,
I fell in love with physics
and I felt like, should I change?
Should I not?
And then because of
this professor's advice,
I decided to go for it.
And now in my second year,
since I started Yale,
I'm falling in love with
the intersection of physics
and computer science,
specifically quantum computing
and I guess my biggest piece of advice
is to maintain an open attitude
to take classes that interest you
and being willing to embrace changes
in what you wanna study.
- Absolutely.
You know, I think when I entered
or when I was first interested
in quantum information sciences
because of all the potential, right?
Like the potential of quantum
advantage, the potential
to impact, you know, create
impact across industries.
That really interested me.
And the reason why I actually stuck
to quantum information science,
I mean, it was absolutely
very interesting,
but it was because of the people around,
because of the communities that
I was able to take part in.
Because of my roommate
from my second year,
how we kind of worked together, you know,
worked through some of these concepts.
And I think because of that community
I was able to really prosper in
and continue to develop my interest
into now it is my passion and
what I'll probably continue
to do for the rest of my life. Yeah.
- Since you're talking,
can you say a little bit more
about the Yale quantum computing
cloud that you organized?
- Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
And that you helped us launch, Florian.
But yeah, last fall we
created the Yale undergrad
quantum computing group.
Looking back I think
there are three reasons
that I started up this group.
The first was to make that community right
that I talked about
because I was lucky enough
to have a suite-mate who was
interested in the same thing
but having like a club, having
sort of an organization there
for students who are just starting out,
who are really interested and who need
that sort of support network
would be very useful.
So that was the first
thing to build community.
The second thing was
because I wanted to reach
people who were interested
in quantum computing but
they didn't have this sort
of background in physics
or computer science, right?
They came from other STEM fields,
they came from non STEM fields
and they had that amazing
potential to make impact,
but they didn't...
I mean, no one had really
like told them that, you know,
this is something that you can do.
So, yeah.
So it was a cool club where people
from interdisciplinary
backgrounds could come in
and create impact.
And the third reason was
because I wanted to work on cool projects.
(Jha chuckles)
And I wanted to work on
cool projects with people
from different backgrounds
and different perspectives.
I think that's where the
coolest projects come from
when you have people that come
from different backgrounds.
Yeah. So, and I think all those
three reasons were achieved
and will continue to, I guess like be met
in the coming years.
- Thank you.
The fact that we're mixing so many people
across so many disciplines
is also the challenge
of this technology and this field,
because we are going to
need a lot of people.
And so there's not a single...
It's great for all of you trying
to consider career in quantum,
but it's also a little
bit difficult for us
to give you one answer because
you can enter the field
in so many different ways.
That's something that's very challenging.
And I think the US is trying to help that
by launching initiative like
the center for quantum network
for all the different hubs,
national hubs of the quantum initiatives.
Is it something that you can
talk a little bit more about,
Steve, about this center?
- Yeah, so
the first thing to understand is
that quantum computing is at
a very early stage, right?
You know, maybe we've invented
the quantum Abacus or,
you know, some very crude
versions of computers exist,
but they're not that useful yet.
And so we have many problems to solve
and it's going to take a while.
So young people, your age are
needed to come into the field
to help us solve these problems
over the next 10 or 20 years
or however long it takes.
And so the center that I direct, C2 QA
is a very large national center.
There are 24 institutions,
five federal labs,
18 universities and IBM
as our industrial partner
because they have experience, you know,
physicists are not system builders
or even computer scientists.
And so, you know, people
with industrial experience
are of course valuable.
And what's called the
technology readiness level
is just very low.
There are many, many problems to solve
and you can contribute whether
you're a mechanical engineer
electrical engineer, a computer
scientist, a physicist,
a material scientist, a chemist.
We're trying to invent an
entirely new type of technology
and no one person or even
no group of people all
from the same background
could possibly solve
all the engineering
challenges that we face.
So it's that, again means
there are many routes
for you to enter this field.
And it means that centers
like the one that I direct
are important precisely because
they bring together people
who haven't been talking
to each other before.
So I now have a chance.
I'm now collaborating
with computer scientists
that I had, you know, I
just I know very little
about computer science that they know.
I know a little, they know
a little bit about physics
and a little bit about quantum computing
and we're working together to try to think
about how do you write
programs for quantum computers?
How do you compile them?
How do you get them to work
even though the hardware
is still not very reliable?
There are people that
are electronic, you know,
work with high speed
electronics or people that,
you know, just come from
all kinds of backgrounds.
And so it's really an opportunity
to build communities
with diverse backgrounds
to try to tackle these big challenges.
- Well, speaking of that,
like how do you have...
Like you have all these
avenues to enter this field,
but like how do you decide
which one is good for you?
Can one of you panelists tell me,
like if you had, like, what
kind of experience you had
to sort of like try different things.
Like, is there tools
online that you can use?
Like what kind of activities you can do?
I'm hinting at maybe a
hackathon, just some means.
(Florian laughs)
One of you want to talk about that?
- Yeah. I can say a bit
about expand on that hint.
Yeah. We had this fantastic event,
the quantum coalition hack
that I have helped lead.
And this is really incredible
event because I mean,
we had sponsorship from
companies across the world.
So our biggest sponsors were
IBM and Q-CTRL and Google.
And we had a ton of other sponsors.
And I think the coolest thing though,
was that we had 2000 people sign up,
1,400 people participate in some way
and 200 teams of like 3 to
5 people submit projects.
And this shows how much
interest there is out there.
And this hackathon
was conducted completely virtually, right?
So without needing to go
into a lab, without needing
to even have a very strong laptop,
we had sponsors that would
provide online interfaces
that you could use
if you didn't have very powerful
computing tools at home.
I think this is a testament to
how many resources now exist
on the cloud that are free to use.
So I also I'm an IBM Qiskit Advocate.
So I've had some experience
with Qiskit with contributing
to Qiskit, which is open source.
And I can (faintly speaking)
at least for Qiskit,
there's a ton of tutorials.
Yeah, there's a wonderful online interface
at IBM quantum experience,
and there's a really
hybrid community out there.
So there's like a pupping Slack channel
where you can just ask, you
know, if you're coming in from,
if you're an industry professional,
if you're a college student,
if you're a high school
student, you can just go there
and get some help and get started.
And this is one of the
many tools out there.
So definitely if you're interested,
I would say there are tools
out there to support you.
There are communities
And the best way to get started is to go
through one of these intro tutorials
if you're interested in
quantum information science.
- I just wanna add-
- Go ahead. Go ahead.
- Thank you so much.
I just wanna add one
more note on a hackathon.
So I had just joined UQC as
director of partnerships,
but as I'd mentioned,
I'd literally had my first
quantum computing lecture
a month before.
And then it was my
responsibility to reach out
to all of these sponsors and
ask them to join our hackathon.
And it felt like a pretty big request.
And I was very nervous being
a beginner to the field,
but I was amazed by how
dedicated the sponsors were
to bringing in the next generation
and specifically to bringing
in new perspectives.
I think that's kind of what's special
about the quantum computing community is
that people really understand the need
for interdisciplinary collaboration.
And they're really open
to bringing in beginners.
That's just been really
reassuring and exciting for me
as a beginner to this field.
- So there's all the resources online.
Like I think if you just
do a quick search on Google
about these different things
you will be able to find them.
A few things that we can point out
is that so IBM has a lot of resource,
Qiskit has a lot of also
resources and tutorial.
Google has also a series of videos online.
Microsoft is starting to
ramp up their programming
so that they have more and more things.
And one thing that I can point out it's,
if you give me a second
so I can change my slides
there's these school.
So you can see on my
webcam, the cubitbycubit.org
is a website that has a ton of resources
and they are currently hosting summer camp
for middle school, high
school and college students.
And we have also a quantum, I mean not we,
but like they also have
a quantum summer school
for researchers.
So there's a lot of things available.
And one of the advice that I will give you
if you're interested in the fields
but you don't know exactly what to do,
it's really to try to
follow the tutorials.
There's like some very
short exercise and some,
like it's almost the shape of a homework
and you can like starting with a compiler
and like try to test your very first code
on the quantum computers.
And so to follow on that, Steve,
could you tell us a little bit more,
because I knew that he
used the IBM experience
for your classes.
Can you talk a little bit
more about the interaction
of the students with
these quantum computers?
- Sure. So I'm presently
teaching an undergraduate course
at Yale physics 345
and you don't have to have
any background in physics
to take it.
The only prerequisite
is to know a little bit
about linear algebra,
solving sets of simultaneous
equations, basically.
And so I give some
lectures on the background
and then when students
have a little background,
they can start programming and
stewing homework assignments
on the IBM quantum experience.
Florian is putting up
one of the interfaces that you can use.
And it's very simple,
drag and drop graphical
interface to start.
You don't even have to write code.
You just drop different quantum gates
or operations into a circuit.
And there's a lot of online tutorials
with IBM Q and with Qiskit
to show you how to use this.
And it's a lot of fun
students really enjoy playing.
This is completely free.
You can have access.
You know, as a professor I'm a member
of the education network at IBM.
And so we have a little
extra access to the machines
but anybody, anywhere in the
world is welcome to log in
and start playing with these at no charge.
So if you're curious to
learn a little bit about,
you know, try your hand at some
simple, very simple programs
then you can just go
ahead and start today.
- We have another question
in the Q and A panel
for you Shantanu.
So he's exited that the imagings
that creating an undergrad club
on such a complex and advance
subject is not pretty easy.
He would be interested in
knowing how you prepared
and study, you know, to
like emperor enough people
to propose the creation of this club.
- Yeah, it's a good question
and, you know, something
that I grappled with
when I was thinking
starting this organization
You know, because Yale
has a really rich history
in quantum information science
and quantum engineering.
And yeah, I thought, you know, is it okay
for me to create a club like this?
And I think what motivated me
was we had an interest meeting
and there were a lot of undergraduates
that were interested
in such a club, right?
And they came.
We actually, as I like to look
at the numbers and we had,
I think we had like 10
or 15 different majors
outside of physics and
computer science and math
that were interested in
joining such a club, right?
That wouldn't have had access
to these amazing resources,
this like rich history that
and graduate community at Yale
if not for a club like this.
So that's why I continued with it
and that's how I got the motivation
and asked for how I got the
resources to support this.
I find that a lot of the resources
were already kind of there.
And I just had to reach out to ask.
So I asked professor Girvin
and he was really helpful.
And I asked Florian, he was very helpful.
And I think the best thing
that I could have done
and I did was gathered
really talented board
of people who were like ILA
who were really enthusiastic
about such a venture.
So I should note, you know,
that's like more of like a motivation
and a little bit of
advice, surround yourself
by people who are
interested and passionate
if you're trying to
start a club like this.
And on a more practical note,
there's a quantum collision
hack that we mentioned before
is not gonna be contained to
quantum collision hackett.
It's actually kind of like a cool network
of universities across the world.
So if you're at a university
and you need some support
in starting the club, you
can just join our discord,
good or a site quantumcollision.io.
And we're also gonna host a
webinar where we kind of talk
about how to create a club.
And this is, I mean,
I know there are a ton
of resources out there.
And so we're gonna try
to work with everyone
so that we're not like,
so that we're taking full
advantage of all the synergies.
So the main point there
is that there are people
who are interested in such a thing.
And there are a lot of people
interested in working with you
to create cool clubs like
quantum computing clubs.
- And I can add to this that
there was an opinion piece
written, I think six months ago.
And then the main concern
and the main limiting factor
of quantum science will be the workforce,
because we are the point where
we don't have enough people
trained on all of these fields.
And so the reason why it's
so important these days
and why everybody from the tech giants
to the university to
the high school teachers
that like really trying to
bring together the workforces
because going to be the limiting factor.
And so I think you can
use that to your advantage
and like reach out to people and say,
"Oh, I'm a high school student
I'm interested in doing that.
Can you help me do that?"
And I'm pretty sure you
will have all your answer.
Like, yes, please, here.
Like, we can help you with this thing.
These are some resources here,
like you can read on to that.
And so that's really
something that's gonna be...
So the field is challenging
because it's a new field.
And so it's gonna be a
lot of work for everybody,
but there's also we are in
really good shape right now.
This is the perfect
time to join this field
because that's gonna be the time
where everybody wants you to have.
Somebody with a quantum background
will be really looked for
on the job markets after that.
And so since this session
is to prepare for college
and if you're like on your
first year of college,
maybe we can ask Kelly,
like what are the advice
that you can give as a recruiter to like,
how can you put your best
chances to enter a college
and then study those fields?
- Sure. So I can kind of
speak from the perspective
of our engineering program
at the university of Arizona.
And it's good to keep in mind
that every institution
is going to be different
in terms of their process
and the programs they offer.
But as we mentioned,
you know, the cool thing
about this field is that you can come out
from a variety of different backgrounds.
So I loved Ayelet's advice
about having an open mind.
And I think that is super important
as you're going through
your college search process
as you're thinking about
what you want to major in.
And it is okay as a high school
student to not know today
or when you're applying
what exactly you want to do
for the next four years.
So that's one of my biggest
pieces of advice too
is to just be curious, have an open-minded
and pursue the things
that you really enjoy.
So the way our program at
the university of Arizona
is set up in our engineering school
is actually all of our
engineering students
come into the college.
They don't choose a major right away.
So we have a built-in
first semester course
where you actually meet all, now 16,
we just added a major
in software engineering
that was announced this week.
So we have 16 programs now
that you get to pick from.
So if you have a career path
in mind, you may find a variety
of majors that really speak
to what your future goal is.
So if your future goal is in quantum,
you may want to pursue physics
instead of engineering,
you may want to pursue
software engineering
or material science.
I know our department head
here in material science
at the university of
Arizona, he's also working
on a quantum computing
project using sound.
So there's a lot of different
ways that you can add
onto your college experience
outside of your major.
So these research
opportunities, internships,
those are all things
that can supplement you
as you're going through.
So it's okay to not know right now exactly
what the next four years
are gonna look like.
Just keep an open mind.
And I would say, as you know, my advice
as an admissions person is if
you're interested in a career
in any one of the science
fields or engineering or math,
in high school pursue as many
of those courses as you can,
as much math especially
calculus based math.
For engineering, that's
super important for us.
Math and science in high school.
Take whatever you can,
get involved in clubs
whatever they may be whether
it's coding or robotics
or whatever interests you.
And you're gonna have a
great foundation coming in
having taken those courses.
And it's really gonna
set you up for success,
you know, transitioning
into college level physics,
chemistry, calculus,
all of those things
coming in your first year.
So there's lots of ways to slice it.
But I would say the more
that you can pursue those
foundations in high school,
the more prepared and
confident you'll feel coming
into a university setting
where you're using all
of those skills and building upon them.
- Thank you.
We're gonna take a question from Jimmy
in the the Q and A panel.
He says that he recently completed
the IBM QxQ coding school.
And there's like a lot of
online school that you can take.
And most of the positions I've seen are
for PhD's or engineers.
And so I think that's the case for now.
A lot of people, since we
are at the very beginning
of the fields, it's much
easier for a research center
to develop this kind of work,
but I think it's gonna expand
to different kind of position.
But can one of you in the panel tell us,
like, what do you think
the workforce will be
in the short term and in the longterm?
Like, will it be a shift
between like only PhDs or
is it gonna be the part
to turn of like more
engineers, more masters?
What kind of diploma
should you get for now?
I know it's a bit of a tough question
because we don't know what
the field is gonna reflect,
but if one of you can
try to (indistinct) that,
that would be great.
- I mean, I could actually
maybe chime in a little bit
about this.
So just kind of based
on some of the research
that's out there, just
because things are...
And some of this is my opinion too,
but just kind of early
on since a lot of this
is still being figured out and developed
that there's kind of a need for PhDs
and kind of scientists
kind of lay that groundwork
and then later on for
masters students and so on
to kind of then come in
and execute these things.
So that's kinda my thought.
- I could add a little bit.
I mean, you know, right now,
quantum computers are hand
assembled mostly by PhDs,
mostly physicists, some
engineers, but you know,
the field is evolving so
rapidly and there's no way
that we can, you know, expect somebody
to become an electrical engineer
and then take another six
years and get a PhD also
in quantum physics.
We have to find ways for
people to start contributing,
give them easy ways to learn enough
about the basics of quantum
so they can bring their expertise
from whatever field they're in
to bear on the numerous problems
that we're trying to solve.
So this is actually a
big question in industry
and for the federal government right now.
How do we learn how to do that?
I'm part of a panel
that was at an NSF, national
science foundation workshop
to try to figure out just
how do you create courses
for undergrads to get
them introduced to quantum
and what should the requirements be
and what should you teach
for the beginners and the
more advanced students.
It's such a new field.
We're still figuring this out.
And going back to the things
that Kelly was saying earlier,
you know, what is the
best you can contribute?
You can get into this field
from almost any field.
And what you should pick
to work on in college
is just whatever you're excited about.
It doesn't matter.
When you go, you know, you
can use that as some expertise
in that area plus a little
study or one course,
or, you know, personal
effort to learn a little bit
about quantum to get yourself an entree.
It really doesn't matter.
It's more important to be passionate
about something and use
that passion to learn
than to say, "Oh, I wanna get into quantum
and I should study this, even though
it's not the thing I'm
most excited about."
That's a mistake.
And you know, you're gonna
major in something in college.
You may change your
mind what your major is.
That's what college is for.
It's the one time in your life
when you can explore and try out things.
And after college, you might decide to go
to graduate school and
get a master's degree
and it might be in a different field.
You might move from electrical
engineering to physics
or vice versa.
That's not uncommon.
And so don't try to think there are some
absolutely single best route to take.
There are many ways in and
you should take the one
with the most interesting
scenery along the route.
- That's a very good point.
To talk about personal experience,
when I was never really
like in high school.
I really hated school.
I didn't really want to continue.
So I went to a vocational
school for two years
and then slowly and slowly I was like,
well, you've done enough work.
And then maybe you can
do an (indistinct) school
in the back.
And then I went to grad
school and then I went
to postdoc and then I
ended up in this position.
And so really like, if you
have a plan, that's great,
but also there's a ton of
opportunities everywhere.
And so if you need limit self to one thing
you might miss out on really
fascinating opportunities
that you might have.
Yeah. College is a
really good time for that
to try to figure out what to do
and what you like and what you don't like,
because sometimes it's
also very much easier
to figure out what you don't like.
You take one class of intro of,
I don't know something about...
I don't want to like
pinpoint on the matter
because somebody is gonna be mad
(Florian chuckles)
since we have so many,
we have a president here,
but yeah, you could you realize
if you like the subject note
and then you can decide what to do.
- Yeah. Maybe I can add a
quick note from the perspective
of someone who was looking at some
of these job opportunities,
both to collect them
for our club.
And also just cause I'd interested
cause I'm working currently
and I'm working for a bit
before I go to grad school.
I'm working as a software engineer.
And that's my first point.
So the skills that you
develop when working
in quantum information science,
working on these projects
are very transferable and
that goes both ways, right?
Like you can come in from any background,
you can also pursue any,
like a lot of different things afterwards.
So it's a very worthwhile effort.
And when going to college,
(technical hitch drowns
The speaker) give is,
yeah. Doing wanna do.
And also if you're
interested in something,
don't be afraid of like really diving deep
and getting your hands dirty.
Yeah. Well, that will be time well spent.
Yes. So yeah.
So another thing I want
to note is I looked
at these job postings and I've seen some
really cool roles pop up.
So at companies like Amazon and Google,
I see software developer roles pop up
that don't require a PhD background.
So this is kind of like to the point
of building the infrastructure, right?
Necessary to achieve something
like quantum advantage
at a large scale, you don't
just need physics PhDs.
You also need software engineers
and a lot of other people
throughout the stack, right?
So to speak of quantum computing.
Yeah. So there are a lot
of transferable skills
and there are opportunities
that are already popping up
and will continue to pop up.
- Maybe that's a good time to
present the upcoming events
that we have in this series.
Give me one second.
Here we go.
Because since there's so many careers,
we have a series of events.
So the next one will be for
preparing for grad school
because of course, as somebody mentioned,
PhD are very important right now,
but then we have some
more panels to cover.
Like most of the different
positions you can get.
So grad school would be in June.
In August we'll have four faculty members
for young post-docs who
wants to go in academia
and try to get tenure under university.
In October we'll have a panel on startups.
So all the work that has
been done by the startups
and most of the quantum computer,
the big player in the role started
from startups from university.
So I think we have the
phase where the startup
are transitioning into
these big tech giants.
So that's gonna be an
exciting, an exciting time.
And then in December we'll
have for industry jobs
and what you can do to
make yourself more valuable
in the field.
And I think that will be one
that will be very interesting.
Like had a couple of questions
about that in the chats.
We are almost running out of time.
Maybe we can look at back to each of you
and you can tell us in a minute or so
your hot take on how we
could prepare for college
and what's the the advice
you can give to our audience?
Maybe I should start...
Who wants to start?
All right.
I'm going to pinpoint on that.
Ayelet you want to
start last word on that?
- Yeah, sure.
I do wanna reiterate what I said before
and what Kelly echoed about
maintaining an open attitude.
And I also wanna emphasize
that you can find a way
to contribute to quantum
if you have a desire to learn.
It is often an intimidating
field, but if you have
that desire to learn no
matter how beginner you are,
you can find a way to contribute.
- Shantanu?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So on, I guess more general
advice note, try to find someone
with whom you can actually
learn this material.
That's really helpful to have
someone there to motivate you.
And on more practical note,
if you're interested in like
quantum information science
in particular and actually
running these circuits,
I would say, the only requisite
would be learning a bit
about how matrices work with each other.
So like how they add and
how they multiply vectors.
And I think that's like
from a practical standpoint.
And in terms of opportunities,
you don't have to wait for an internship.
You don't have to wait for
like some opportunity come up
in terms of like a formal program.
You can start contributing
to open source projects.
For example, if you're
interested in computer science,
you can find the Qiskit Qithub repos
and you can start contributing right away.
So, yeah.
So don't be afraid to get started.
Find someone to help motivate you
and to bounce off ideas with.
And if you can, if you're interested,
try to learn a bit about linear algebra,
I think that'd be really helpful.
- Russell?
- So I think I'll echo
kind of some of the stuff
that's come up here.
Find a major or find a field
that you're interested in.
You know, do some research
about the different pathways.
We've talked about some of them today,
but I think find something
that you really enjoy
and that you can be passionate about.
And you'll find a way in to,
you know, the quantum workforce
and just keep an eye out
for different opportunities
to get involved with outreach
or some of the extracurriculars
that we've talked about.
I think that's gonna be really important
because that's more of
informal kind of laid back way
to kind of test, you know,
if you're gonna enjoy this
and making connections
with people too at those events.
- Kelly?
- Sure. I guess one maybe
kind of different thing
that we haven't discussed
that's on my mind this week
is May 1st as you may have
heard this traditional
kind of national college decision day.
So I've been talking to a
lot of high school students
and parents this week who
are just really worried.
They don't wanna make the
wrong decision in their words.
And so I would just say
don't worry a lot about
something like that.
There are so many wonderful
programs in the US
and around the world
related to these fields.
And really it's just about
finding a place that you feel
like is a place you wanna
spend the next four years
that feels comfortable to you,
that feels welcoming to you.
And so don't worry so much
about picking the wrong school
or the wrong program or the wrong major.
You'll find your path as
you go through college.
And really it's about finding a place
that feels like home to you.
So if you're able to do campus visits
when you're doing your college search
or talking to other students.
I know one of the things
I do a lot in my job
is connect high school
students to current undergrads
to talk about things like research
or their experience or
internships or whatever it may be.
So just have an open mind,
apply to any place that interests you.
And then if you can try to visit and focus
on picking a place that feels like you
and you'll be successful.
- Thank you.
Steve, last word?
- Yeah. So, you know, just as it's easier
to learn languages when you're young,
I think it's easier to learn
mathematics when you're young.
And so as Shantanu mentioned,
really the minimum mathematics
you need to know about
to enter this field is linear algebra,
how to solve simultaneous equations,
how to work with matrices and vectors.
And there are wonderful
websites like Three Blue,
One Brown, where you can see
amazingly wonderful videos
that teach you these things.
And you can start there.
You can take a course
when you get to college.
And I would learn that
first, I would, you know,
probability and statistics turns out
to also be an important part of quantum
because there's a certain randomness
in the way quantum mechanics works.
And that's a very, very
important area anyway
in modern data-driven society.
And so that'll be a skill,
even if you end up not going
into quantum or not
even going into science,
it'll make you a better citizen.
You can understand, you know,
the statistics that
people are using to argue
for different policies.
So I would, if I had to pick
one thing to suggest you study,
it's discrete mathematics.
- All right.
So I would like to conclude on this thing.
Thank you all to the panel.
Thank you all for attending.
And thank you also for your time
for all the panelists who are here.
I hope you learned a lot
about what we're doing.
We have posted in the chat a lot of links.
So we had some of the videos
that we're talking about,
One Brown, some of the websites
that you can find the resources
and then otherwise
Google is really helpful.
If you do a quick search, you
should find a ton of things
and don't forget to ask people.
So that'd be great.
Thank you all.
And we hope to see you next time.
So yeah, our next event will be,
if I pick the dates will be
on June 18 at 2:00 p.m Pacific time
and 5:00 p.m Eastern time.
So if you're interested in that,
please let us know in your registration.
You had a place to receive
email for the upcoming events.
So we will send that shortly.
Thank you all and have a
great rest of your morning,
rest of your afternoon
or everywhere you're in the world.
Thank you.
Bye.